today in the United States one pregnancy
in five fails to produce a living
healthy child 126,000 mentally [ __ ]
children are born each year millions
more suffer from various defects
infections are among the preventable
causes of abortions stillbirths and
damaged infants
research on the relationship between
infections and birth defects is the
major assignment of the section on
infectious diseases perinatal research
branch national institute of
neurological diseases and blindness the
section works directly with other
Institute's including Allergy and
Infectious Diseases and Child Health and
Human Development all within the federal
government's Department of Health
Education and Welfare a number of
infections can cause abnormal pregnancy
outcomes
these include rubella cellar Miguel a
conclusion disease robiola mumps herpes
simplex disease western equine
encephalitis chickenpox smallpox vaccine
ear
polio hepatitis Coxsackie B virus
influenza syphilis tuberculosis
toxoplasmosis the perinatal research
branch serves as research headquarters
for 14 medical centers throughout the
nation which participate with the
neurology Institute in the collaborative
perinatal Research Project a study of
birth defect causes this young woman
mrs. Owens represents one of 50,000
mothers who with their infants are
taking part in this collaborative
project in addition to infections
genetic obstetrical and other perinatal
factors will be considered in the study
mrs. Owens will give blood at intervals
to aid in the study of infections of
pregnancy her child will contribute
smaller amounts of ceará at specified
intervals each time mrs. Owens blood is
taken 40 milliliters is collected in 220
milliliter vacutainer tubes
the specimens provided by mrs. Owens are
allowed to clot at room temperature then
placed in a refrigerator overnight to
provide maximal retraction of the clot
this procedure allows the technicians to
obtain a maximal yield of serum that
fraction of the blood containing the
reactive particles to be studied tubes
are ringed to loosen the clot prior to
separating clot from serum in the
centrifuge specimens are spun for 15
minutes at 2,000 revolutions per minute
in a refrigerated centrifuge
next a technician employs a twenty or
twenty five milliliter pipette to pool
the serum from the two tubes into a
single container
the serum is then transferred to for one
gram vials the contents of each vial can
be used several times for different
tests the blue line indicates a critical
3 milliliter mark if filled beyond this
mark the vial might break during
freezing or thawing
packets of Syrah are stored at -15 to
-20 degrees centigrade
cartons are filled with the packets
fifty pounds of dry ice will keep the
specimens frozen for four days even at
summer temperatures
shipments are made to the serum center
section on infectious disease Bethesda
Maryland
the specimens are logged in by coding
clerks at the serum Center
each specimen is checked for quantity
and quality good quality frozen serum is
straw-colored
records are prepared
the packets are placed in aluminum trays
then they are stored at minus 20 degrees
centigrade in one of the four serum
Center freezers more than 1 million
specimens are available for testing
priorities for study are determined at
staff conferences for example during the
German measles epidemics rubella virus
was investigated extensively as a result
of the staff conference statistical
personnel using the records in the serum
center select the serie of patients to
be tested a tally sheet prepared after
the selection enables personnel to
locate the Sira
the vials to be tested are taken from
their trays placed in polystyrene blocks
and transported to the laboratory these
lightweight polystyrene blocks tailored
to the needs of the section each hold up
to 200 vials a micro technique has been
perfected to simplify extend and speed
up the testing it employs smaller tools
smaller test amounts yet gives reliable
results with countless blood tests to
perform ordinary procedures would not be
feasible when the vials of ceará have
thawed an automatic diluting machine
mixes one part of thawed serum with
three parts of saline the dropper takes
up the serum then flushes it off with
the saline
in preparation for the test each cup in
this disposable plastic plate receives a
drop of saline solution
long handled loops calibrated to pick up
0.025 milliliters of solution are dipped
into the various Serie specimens several
loops can be handled simultaneously each
contains a different specimen one of the
loops holds the solution made from the
Syrah contributed by mrs. Owens
the stylist of each loop is rotated in
the fingertips to ensure good mixing the
loops carry solution from one row to
another for serial dilutions
specific antigen is added by pipette a
drop measures 0.025 millilitres mumps
antigen for example is added by using
different antigens derived from various
microorganisms the section is testing
for more than 100 infections which are
of importance to man to determine to
what extent they may contribute to birth
defects the red line marks a serum
control which receives no antigen this
will pick up false positive reactions
few false positive reactions occur next
complement is added to the antibody
antigen mixture complement is a
substance that takes part in the
reaction of antibody with antigen and
provides an indirect measurement of the
reaction the plates are refrigerated at
4 degrees centigrade for 16 to 18 hours
this gives time for the fixation of
complement if any to take place if mrs.
Owens Sarah has mumps antibodies
evidence that she has been exposed to
this virus the antibodies would react
with the antigen at the same time
complement is being fixed or used up as
part of the reaction next day sensitized
sheep red blood cells are added with a
point O 5 milliliter dropper they will
provide a way to detect whether
complement remains in the test solution
or has been fixed
the place are sealed with a press
taken to a 37 degrees centigrade walk-in
incubator and placed in the shaking
machine for 15 minutes
after shaking the plates remain in the
incubator for an additional 30 minutes a
sedimentation period of four hours at
room temperature is routine to allow any
red cells that were not broken up or
lysed
by unfixed complement to settle
a centrifuge speeds up the process of
concentrating intact cells
the test plates are ready to read
infection is evident when the reaction
between antibody and antigen fixes
complement then complement is not free
to lyse the red cells as a result the
positive test appears as a button of red
cells in a negative test there is no
such accumulation of intact red cells
they are broken up and the liquid
appears pink the more diluted samples
had less antibody and a less apparent
button of red cells in a positive test
the button is decidedly visible the data
on infections is a vital part of the
mother's history other variables such as
age number of previous pregnancies
manner of delivery also are recorded
the IBM cards become masses of
information to be fed into modern
electronic computers these can give
answers in days that formerly would have
taken months to acquire the computers
enables scientists to correlate millions
of bits of information to view related
events from new perspectives
however the judgment of highly trained
investigators is essential in analyzing
this data on birth abnormalities
correctly the section of infectious
diseases conducts a number of related
studies employing a variety of test
methods for example the fluorescent
antibody technique permits the viewer to
see fluorescent labeled antibody
attached to specific antigen ultraviolet
light excites the fluorescence literally
spotlighting the reaction
tissue cultures of placenta and cord are
studied to detect pathogenic effects of
viruses a characteristic pattern of cell
destruction identifies certain viruses
animals are studied including ferrets
and monkeys pregnant rhesus monkeys are
injected with rubella virus or other
agents to determine at what stage in
development of the fetus effects might
be observed an infant monkey is
delivered by caesarian to see whether
virus can be recovered from organs or if
defects are occurring mrs. Owens and
other mothers participating in the study
the laboratory workers hospital and
clerical personnel special testing
procedures all are a part of the
research story on infections and birth
defects
the accomplishments of this research and
of the overall perinatal studies will
become part of medical communications
useful to family doctors obstetricians
pediatricians and other specialists
throughout the world
you